The answer is that find will return negative one. When
the target string is not found in the search string.
Of the four examples here there are two where that's
the case. For both of these, it is found, so
in the first example we're looking for t within the
string test. It occurs in two places. But it'll find
the first one, so the result of this find will
be zero. For this one we're looking for the string st.
Strings are the same whether they have single or double
quotes. It doesn't matter what we use, as long as we're
consistent with the first and the end quote. And in
this case we find the string st at position two, so
that would return two. For this one we used an
upper case t, a lower case here. The find has to
match exactly, it has to be the same character and case
matters. So this would return negative one, and would be correct
that this is one of the examples that returns
negative one. And for the final one, we're searching
for the string test, within the string west. They
don't match exactly; so this would also return negative one.